foreign
what's up Amy
hi Dr John how are you partying what are
you up to rocking on to break it on what
are you doing
you're in Vegas
yes
[Laughter]
all right so what's up yes this is Vegas
um okay so I have a question for you
um I've been seeing my therapist for
about three years now okay in that time
we've become good friends no no no no no
oh no
um and I've hung out at our house I've
met her family no run
unethical therapist
right rule number one
I don't even know why I don't know
[Music]
I just totally interrupted you like how
could I help him okay
um so we you know we've done a lot of
stuff together we've hung out
we've got a therapist dude report this
therapist they should have no license
they should have their license taken
away they are unethical
is it a male or male or female
it's she's a it's a female okay are you
all in a romantic relationship
no no
um so she she the first time she invited
me to her house I was really happy that
she invited me of course
no you're allowed to do whatever you
want you're a grown-up she is not she is
a licensed professional
yeah it's a it's a core violation it's
the it's one of the chorus violations
here here's why here's it's called a
dual relationship it's highly unethical
here's why
friendship is the giving and taking of
presence right this back and forth of
love and deep understanding and the
promise
that come what may
all hold your burdens and you'll hold
mine
yeah in a professional therapeutic
relationship is entirely one-sided you
are paying another person to sit with
you in your burdens
there can be there can never be an
expectation or realized the therapist
doing their reverse asking you to hold
her burdens her friendship come to my
house do our things highly manipulative
highly unethical
there should never be contact with the
client listen here's how here's how Wild
it gets
um
I had a client once that was speaking at
an event I was at
and I had a ques nobody in that room
knew nobody
um I I've got colleagues who they they
when they introduce themselves to their
clients they will say if I see here's a
common thing they say it this way if I
see you in a grocery store I'm gonna
walk right by you
I will not acknowledge you and it's
going to be weird because you just told
me about all this crazy sex stuff
between you and your husband and your
your boyfriend that you're having an
affair with it's gonna feel weird that
we had these intimate conversations and
I just walked straight past you at a
grocery store
but I'm gonna honor confidentiality so
much I'm gonna honor the professional
relationship so firmly now you can go
run up and hug your therapist and be
like I don't care that's fine you're
allowed to do that
um and then once you breach that that
boundary you can hug and say hi whatever
um
but dude it is I I mean I can't tell you
how wrong that is
so there's no situation where that would
be appropriate I think
I have to it's been a while since I I
the the counseling um code of ethics
um I think is five years
after the last session
can you have a relationship and I think
the APA it's been a while since I read
that one but I think that one is never
but I've been a homie to that one but
it's at least an extended period of time
after you write your last check and you
have your last session
unprofessional
okay I think
I think the reason is because she's a
she's an unethical professional that's
the only reason
that's the only reason okay what are you
gonna say I was rude
well she knows that I don't have any
other friends
um and I have a toxic family that I'm
currently
um distancing myself from and I don't
know if she's doing it as a way to try
and help me
um she knows my situation
um and I I just don't know if that's why
she's doing it or she just
I don't know but um I mean she I I would
I would not
um so in Psychology it's called the
fundamental attribution error
where you get inside someone else's head
and try to decide why they're doing
whatever it is they're doing
I would not do that I'd get out of her
head
because even if she's trying to help
what she should be doing okay let's just
use this this example what she should be
doing is teaching you in session
how to be uncomfortable how to ask okay
you want to go hang out and grab coffee
hey let's make a plan for you're gonna
invite three women that you don't know
that well that you work with but you're
gonna invite them over for whatever is
going on
um and then she's gonna be a safe place
for you to go back to during your next
session after the thing is the party's a
disaster or after it goes great
and she's so her job is to teach you
skills and then send you out into the
wild
and in the counseling session you get to
practice those skills the beautiful
thing about the counselor client
relationship is it mimics the real world
it's a safe place for you somebody who's
struggling with relationships someone
who's struggling with a toxic family to
practice
heading back out into the real world
it's unethical when she follows you out
into the real world and says hey hold on
you can't really do this I'll take this
for you and in the same time meets her
own needs by using you
well the thing is she has been such a
godsend to me she's helped me through
the worst times in my life and I I
really value both her friendship and her
expertise as a therapist I just don't
want to lose her
um
I mean I I just I don't I I really enjoy
spending time with her of course you do
of course you do
that's in in quite honestly that's the
problem
I'm gonna use a um I'm gonna use an
analogy that may may not fit may not be
fair but it's the one coming to mind
okay
imagine a buddy of mine tell he's
sitting down and telling me how amazing
his wife is
she loves me
she shows up for me
she listens to me the sex is
unbelievable
like I love my wife
and then
our other buddy at the table says I pay
a woman for sex
I pay her for her time in her
relationship and her interaction
and she listens to me and we talk and we
hang out she invites me over
one of those sounds right and one of
those sounds disgusting
you see what I'm saying
you're you're paying her
I just I know I mean it's unethical
because it's like a one-sided
conversation
a one-sided thing
I'm saying it's unethical because she's
violating the code of ethics or for the
profession
that she is hopefully is licensed and
shouldn't be much longer
she's got a very vulnerable person who's
struggling with family Dynamics who's
struggling with loneliness
and she is using that person a for money
B to fill whatever needs she's filling
even if it's she needs to feel like she
can solve everybody else's problems
and she can make people feel not so bad
about themselves it's not her job her
job is to walk alongside you
teach you skills hold you accountable
call you out
and care for you as you head out into
the into your world
yeah you see what I'm saying and I this
is I can't imagine how heartbreaking
this is for you which is why I'm so
upset about it
well I think I knew what the answer was
but I I think I just needed to hear it
out loud you know
I think you're being used
and I think you're worth more than that
just listening to you I think you would
be a great friend
and I bet you're loyal to a fault aren't
you
oh yeah the world needs more people like
you as friends
I think part of me feels like
I'm not going to be able to find
quote-unquote real friends out there so
I I'm kind of attached to her
and that's her job is to not let you get
that attached to her and she failed you
I'm sorry
yeah
her job is to that discomfort you feel
that fear because your family didn't
didn't show up for you when they should
have your other friends have have
haven't shown up for you have you had
um romantic relationships go sideways
I have yeah so you've got a lifelong
history train tracks of relational pain
and what her job is is to sit with you
in the discomfort not try to take it
away for you
and she tried she took it away from you
and she charged you for it
and so in a way she robbed you of the
opportunity to go out and practice
making friends screw it up be awkward be
weird learn about yourself learn about
what your value is and over time
basically here's what she did you went
and got a personal trainer
and you paid her and she lifts the
weights for you every time y'all y'all
lift
and then when it's over you're not very
strong
and you don't feel confident because you
know you didn't lift any weight
but it was awesome to see that much
weight on the bar
see what I'm saying
yeah that makes sense
well do you think
um I think you should never see her
again you should file on her license the
state of Nevada is what I think
you think even if I stop seeing her as a
therapist that
a friend
I think you're grown-up and you can do
whatever you want
when I run into unethical
I mean I I guess I don't hang out with
guys like that
like one of my closest buddies in the
world his name is John King he's an
amazing friend and he is the CEO of an
HR he's a chief exist he's not a CEO but
he he's a senior leader in an HVAC
company
If he if we were just having drinks one
night and he told me he was like man I I
like to charge extra here and here and
rip these people I wouldn't hang out
with him
yeah like I don't I don't want those
people in my life my friends aren't like
that
I think I'm just having trouble
um figuring it out or understanding why
exactly it's unethical
I go go back in here's the deal go back
and listen to call and because I walk
you through it and what you're gonna
start doing is you're gonna spiral
because she's been your only she's been
come she's become your oxygen tank
and she oh gosh
how about this have her call me
have her call the show I'd love to talk
to her
let's do that
and you can just be a fly on the wall
for that conversation she won't call but
there's there's the Dare Amy's therapist
you unethical shouldn't have a life I'm
just gonna shut up